[dramatic music]
NARRATOR: Along a roughly
25-mile stretch of shore,
there have been
more than 60 shark
attacks since records began
and almost half of them fatal.
In fact, this small area
accounts for almost 50%
of recorded attacks in
the entire continent.
As a result, it's earned a
chilling designation as South
America's deadliest coastline.
[water splashes]
ANDRE AFONSO: In
Recife, the shark
attack problem is very serious.
It's probably one of the
most dangerous cities
in the world for having a swim.
NARRATOR: Residents
are at their wits end.
I want to know why it
happens here and always here.
NARRATOR: In an attempt to
prevent further attacks,
authorities banned
surfing in certain areas,
and signs line the beaches
warning of the dangers
of entering the ocean.
But the only real way to
stop this bloody barrage
is to figure out how it started.
FABIO HAZIN: It's
absolutely crucial
to find the cause of the
problem because, if we don't, we
can't build a solution.
NARRATOR: So what's driving
this terrifying onslaught
along with Recife's shores?
And could other coastal
resorts be next?
According to former
instructor Fernando Clark,
something makes diving
in this area unique.
And it hides deep
beneath the waves.
Recife is the shipwrecked
capital off Brazil.
NARRATOR: The area
around the attack zone
is home to dozens of
sunken vessels, some
dating as far back
as the 16th century.
But according to Clark,
these ill-fated ships are
more than just rusty relics.
FERNANDO CLARK: The
shipwrecks become a reef
completely full of marine life.
NARRATOR: Fish,
crustaceans, and mollusks
call these down vessels home.
But it's what these marine
inhabitants attract that could
be problematic for people.
FERNANDO CLARK: When you
go shipwreck diving here,
most of the time we
see a lot of sharks.
NARRATOR: The presence
of sharks near shipwrecks
is a phenomenon that can
be seen elsewhere too.
In the US, sunken
vessels along the shores
of Oregon, Florida,
and North Carolina
are inhabited by
these predators.
The sharks are
attracted to the shipwreck
because of the food.
NARRATOR: So could
the wrecks of Recife
be responsible for luring
dangerous predators
near shore where people are?
Clark says the answer comes
down to the species of shark
he sees most often on his dives.
To demonstrate, he plunges
into the shark-infested waters.
[water splashes]
[gentle music]
Before long, he spots just
what he's looking for--
nurse sharks.
[energetic music]
Nurse sharks are
bottom dwellers,
attracted to the
crustaceans inhabiting
Recife's sunken ships.
Measuring up to 9 feet,
they possess powerful jaws
with serrated teeth.
And, worldwide, they
have been implicated
in multiple attacks on humans.
So could nurse sharks be
responsible for Recife's spike?
Dr. Fabio Hazin is one
of the lead investigators
trying to get to
the bottom of what's
happening along this coast.
And when he analyzes the
details of each incident,
he comes to an
important conclusion.
FABIO HAZIN: Nobody in Recife
has ever reported being
attacked by the nurse shark.
So the shipwrecks are not at
all to blame for the attacks.
NARRATOR: Instead,
Hazin's analysis points
to two other suspects,
both of which
have reputations for
attacking humans.
The first one is tiger sharks.
NARRATOR: Tiger sharks can
grow up to 18 feet in length
and weigh in at 1,400 pounds.
Known for their
undiscerning palates,
they're equipped with
sharp, serrated teeth
that allow them to
rip through seabirds,
turtles, and even people.
[dramatic music]
Perhaps even more imposing
is the other culprit
Hazin implicates in the spike.
And that is bull sharks.
[energetic music]
NARRATOR: Bull sharks bite
with the most force pound
for pound of any large shark.
They are fast and aggressive.
And they're often found in the
same shallow coastal waters
as humans.
So it appears
tigers and bulls may
be responsible for the spike.
The question is, why?